hallo Leute willkommen mein Name ist
rosiamas ich bin von Y-Titty und hätte
meine Frage wieso erwarten alle von
deutschen Comedians mit türkischen
Migrationshintergrund dass sie die Shows
auch ihre Herkunft entsprechend
gestalten also wieso kann ein fatisch
dasselbe wie ein Stefan
wenn du auf die Bühne gehst nimmst du
dich selber mit so und da du halt nicht
der der Hans bist und der blonde
Deutsche auf diesem
Landstrich sondern offensichtlich
woanders herkommst musst du das äh
thematisieren und behandeln verhandeln
und irgendwie beantworten so das ist äh
das ist wichtig
im ersten Programm war das war das sehr
stark er kommt zu Fazit gibt es einen
Block über Vorurteile wo das vielleicht
auch noch mal so ein bisschen verhandelt
wird ich habe im nächsten Programm wird
das gar nicht mehr so sehr ins Gewicht
fallen das ist etwas was man mit der
Zeit abarbeitet dazu noch alles gesagt
und es gibt genug andere Sachen über die
ich reden will und muss ich hoffe ich
habe Dich richtig verstanden und deine
Frage beantworten kann